(audience applauding)
- I'm so excited you're here!
- I'm so excited to see you.
It's been a few years.
- It has, but I have to start with this.
Okay, so "Bite Me" comes out,
with Travis, the single,
and I see the video
and I'm like, were you in
some kind of time capsule?
'Cause you look just like you did.
(audience applauding)
I was like, what?
I was literally watching it
and you did such a great job of like,
you know, people love your sound so much
and I felt like you did such a great job
of like having the sound
that we love you for
but it was progressive.
Like it was different and it was so,
anyway job, well done.
- Aww.
Thank you so much!
- All the way round.
I was like, God.
(audience applauding)
And I love "Bite Me." It was so good.
- Thank you.
- I was so excited about it
and what a way to like, just
come swinging with a single.
Anyway, I just wanted to say that.
And I didn't know this
but you started out in country music?
Or that was your first-
- Kind of.
Like I started singing in
church when I was younger
and then like I sang with
Shania Twain when I was like 14
on stage-
- What?
- And just like country fairs around town.
Then when I got into
high school, I was like,
(Avril squeaking)
and like started writing my own stuff
and developing my sound then
and went off to kind of make my record.
But yeah. Yeah.
- Well, this year is
actually the 20th anniversary
of your album, "Let Go."
What do you remember about making it?
'Cause people ask me,
I've been in the industry
about 20 years too
and it's like-
- Yeah.
- I think how people
perceive things is different
than maybe,
there's a lot of good and bad
that goes on behind the scenes
while making a record.
- Yeah.
- Like what do you remember about it?
- Well, I think making
my first record was hard
because like I wanted to be a songwriter
and I was 15
and like people didn't really like,
like I'd go in the studio
and they were just like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, little girl.
Like you don't know what you're like."
You know what I mean?
- Oh yeah, I got that too.
- And it was kind of like
they were throwing their songs
at me and pitching their songs to me,
which I really didn't like.
And so it was a fight.
It was a fight to write my own music
and then it was a fight
to get the sound I wanted
'cause like I guess like I was
going for like guitar driven-
- Yeah.
- Like music.
I was like, "I just
wanna sound like a band.
I wanna rock."
And that was my challenge.
And so it took like,
I was in New York maybe six months,
working with tons of writers.
It just was not happening.
And then I went through a point
where I think it just like
wasn't working out very great.
And then I went to LA,
and then I finally met with some people,
producers and co-writers
that like listened to me.
And I, at that point had tried so hard
and I was like developing
into like who I wanted to be.
And it worked.
I found people I clicked with.
And so like, yeah.
Like that album took a
while and it was hard
and I had to like fight for
like being a songwriter,
fight to like have the
sound that I wanted,
sit with the producers.
I had no idea what the lingo was.
I was just like, "Make it more rock.
Make it sound more like a band."
But what I wanted just
was guitar driven stuff.
I think it would've been
more polished and poppy
and bubble gum and that
wasn't what I wanted.
So-
- Yeah.
- I made the record I did want though.
- I love that.
And it is true though.
You have to like-
- After all that.
- People push,
especially in the
beginning of my career too,
they push and you're a
teenager and they're like,
"Oh we're gonna make,
you know, write with this person do this."
And it's like, you don't
click with everyone.
- Yeah.
- And there's nothing wrong
with them.
- No.
- But like-
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- You do find your people
that you click really well with.
And then I feel like magic happens, so.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Yeah.
Well I love all your albums, so-
- Thank you.
- I'm so excited
about this one.
So as I mentioned though, your new album
is called "Love Sux,"
which well, sometimes it does.
- Mm-hmm. Let's face it.
- But I heard,
ironically enough,
that you met your new
boyfriend while making it?
- How funny is that?
Like I went into the studio,
I'm literally like,
(Avril sighing)
"Okay, here's where I'm at.
Like, I'm over love.
I need a hot minute.
Like I'm jaded on love right now, like."
- Flick.
- Ugh.
- Yes.
- And like, so you kind
of have to like do that
when you're in your writing sessions.
Just talk about like
where you're at and stuff.
So I wrote that song, "Love Sux."
That set the tone for this album.
Yeah.
And then a couple days
later I had a boyfriend.
(Kelly laughing)
That didn't last very long, did it, Avril?
(audience applauding)
I'm literally never single.
- I love, I know, but
I love that it's like,
you're not wanting it.
It wasn't even-
- Yeah, I know.
- What you were searching for.
- And it was like the
first time in my life,
like I had just like moved
and I moved out to Malibu
and was like starting my life over
and I was like, "All right, like I'm good.
Like I'm just gonna focus
on myself and like do me
and just like give it a break."
Plus I haven't had like the best luck,
but I mean I've had amazing relationships
and they've been like long term.
- Yeah.
- And stuff.
But like I was just kinda like,
"Okay I'm gonna on myself."
And it just like really didn't last.
- It happens.
And you were like, "Or
I'll go on this date."
- Yeah, whatever.
- Well that was awesome.
- But made an album called "Love Sux"
but it's also like super lighthearted
and like funny and fun.
And it's like kind of just
like the ups and downs
of my life in love and just like,
it's a good time and it's-
- Which is relatable.
- Yeah. For sure.
- For a lot of people.
- And like my first
album, it's like, yeah,
am I kind of still
writing in the same (beep)
but like,
(Kelly laughing)
you know,
it's like I was writing when
I got out of high school,
like fresh outta high school.
Just like having crushes
for the first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And now on my seventh album,
it's like my, you know,
I've had experience,
I've lived, I've learned
and men don't change.
- But that's why I think
it was a good thing though.
(Avril laughing)
No, no, no!
No, apparently they stay the same.
(Avril laughing)
No, but I think it's like,
I think it was a good,
like I said, I like that you
kept like the vibe was cool
and like similar to
what we love about you,
but it wasn't the same.
- Yeah.
- I think it's a really cool,
progressive like sound of it.
So, or progressed sound of it, rather.
But I love it.
And I think it's relatable,
doesn't matter how old you are.
We through ups and downs in relationships.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- It happens.
But later in the show,
you're gonna be doing a song called,
"Love It When You Hate Me,"
which I love, that one as well.
It's very sarcastic.
So what's it about?
- Yeah!
It's like a fun, funny take on like,
like being in like a heated,
passionate relationship
where it's like, you know, you're fighting
and then it's and hot and-
- Yeah.
Yeah.
And 'cause then you get the makeup stuff.
- Yeah.
- So there you go.
I kept it family-
- Love that.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
Well everybody, Avril's new
album is called "Love Sux."
You've gotta check it out
and stay with us because she's
performing later in the show.
I'm super stoked!